hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the closing shift this
game has been on my list for a while
it's a japanese game about
chile's coffee where you are running the
closing shift of a coffee shop
which uh if i remember i don't know if
this is by the same person that made
that convenience store game
i can't remember what it is lexian
helped me out inject it into my brain
and then shoot it out my eyeballs
i'm really sorry that i've been asking
you to do such complex things and i'm
sure that you went above and beyond with
that effect and everyone is really
impressed by it i just want to say thank
you
so much
thanks
oh no i'll be late for work i should be
on my car by now
i should be riding on the top of my legs
i have tootsies my right tootsies are
curled up i seem to have a really bad
cramp on my right foot
i am so god damn tall
okay
all right
oh that seems fun hi are you actually an
animal or you
what are you what am i looking at that
seems fine
oh hello
nice clothes
nice
png clothes there's a lovely tiny
apartment
that's a little crazy but all right
shoes who needs them when you got feet
like these when you got tootsies of
steel like mine i just realized i'm
probably not tall
this place is probably just small
okay
wait why why would i
why
why would i wait why would i wait
i'm late
i'm late for a very important date
okay goodbye
[Music]
i'm late i'm going to be late i'm really
worried about being late
time to explore
nope time to go
[Music]
well i don't exactly know who'd be
getting coffee this late but i know
people are up late sometimes so maybe
it's not as crazy as it sounds
what what
what
what
oh hot what
someone's phone
[Music]
hello did someone lose their phone
someone want to come clean this property
before it's mine
okay why do i have the funny feeling
that somebody is watching me
is that my car
time to hop on
well
[Music]
i would love to hop on this car
okay or maybe not
is that my car
no what i need to hop on this car
did i forget something do i need to
return this phone to somebody do i need
to use this phone someone's phone ah
here we go
[Music]
no
did somebody lose a phone do i need to
give a phone back
[Music]
oh hi oh my god hi how what
how would
wait it's so dark
hi excuse me
excuse me
my god
[Music]
i don't mean to say this rudely but your
face sent shivers down my spine and it's
not because i'm in love are you looking
for something well i found this
gimme me it
all right
[Music]
okay pal
[Music]
okay all right
hey bud
man you're handsome all right goodbye
but don't run you over this is my car
i'm gonna go to work now
i spent a little too much time uh trying
to find the owner of that
phone and here i am apparently
that's beautiful
it was really beautiful
oh this is lovely
oh i'm sure nothing horrible can happen
here
i'm sure that everything is going to be
just fine
hi
do i need to wash my hands first
take a piss poop
put my stuff away and talk to senpai
okay
hi
sorry i'm late
funahashi senpai be careful next time
i'm going to tell the manager i'm very
sorry i'll be careful being careful is
not enough
tell me you won't be late do you
understand yes sir i will not be late
again
you also mess up some orders don't you
if you have any trouble with the order
there are some tutorial videos for you
so look through it
okay i'll take a look
oh and one more thing make sure to leave
your phone in the locker you better not
be texting anyone during work
yes sir
i never understood that policy does it
hi ba okay
senpai
uh
oh
[Music]
okay all right that doesn't matter i'm
gonna what i'm gonna close this door now
okay so i need to put away my stuff
what
why why is
why is this why is this like that
why why is why is that
why is hello
weren't you in my house you watching me
you following me
oh
ah oh
oh food tutorial hot drink cold drink
okay
i love cassette tapes
what is that what is it food yeah put it
food grab food
put on plate
or in bag and place on mat
okay
that that's easy enough okay this is hot
drinks i believe okay take the ticket
look at the ticket
go to the
cups coffee
fridge
milk or cream
oat milk perhaps steam it
okay
grab that put that there grab that put
that in there
this is gonna be a little complicated
put it on the tray
put a lid on it
okay i'm not gonna remember any of that
cold drink i imagine pretty similar grab
a cup put ice in it do whatever
cup
oh cold drink is a clear cup so it's
much like starbucks
or non-name brand drink okay blender put
ice in blender put blender in
blendinator
grab cup
put
cream
grab ice
smoothie flavorings i
i am not gonna do good here lid
wow okay
uh i didn't think that i would actually
have to be doing this whole barista
thing
uh but okay
okay locker put away my stuff put that
away oh my god oh my god okay
i'm
i'm trying to inject this into my brain
as much i'll just come back and look at
it i'm i grabbed a mob
put it away put it away put it away a
broom okay
hi
hi how you doing welcome to chilla's
coffee what can i get for you
did you say chill is caught
i i did say chilled coffee i don't know
how you know that i said chili's coffee
but okay i feel uneasy there's something
strange about this place
my daughter seems to be a fan of this
place and now i'm here however
i'll leave the drinks to you oh and i'd
like to get two of them would you want a
latte and a coffee oh that'll be just
fine it's really uncomfortable here
don't know what you mean however how can
you charge such a price for something
like this i don't set the price is sir
i don't set them what did you want a hot
coffee and a
okay coffee dispenser
uh
did you want
just coffee i think i don't think
there's anything crazy about that
okay that's one
um
and you wanted a latte
okay latte
coffee steamed milk okay got it so take
the milk
put the milk pitcher put there put the
milk oh that's soy milk let's get
regular milk bam
[Music]
coffee
usually i would do an espresso
i think
am i supposed to do an espresso
whatever
coffee
probably fine
[Music]
hot cup steamed milk
got that put that there hot cup lid bam
bam bam
uh
hello
take it
did the other one just disappear into
the void
did the other thing just disappear into
the void oh maybe i need to put
milk no that would no
that doesn't make milk
no
no
what
oh oh god
soy milk soy milk ready to serve cup
okay this is what i need
what
take
oh my god what did i do this is a coffee
coffee sticker
yeah
coffee steamed milk
nope no no no no
yeah
buddy all right you have a nice day now
you give me all i do you paid right you
paid right
if that uncomfortable feeling was what
i'm gonna do to you if you didn't pay
all right goodbye
little rude but hey job well done in my
mind
oh hello you're speedy i don't like that
hi how you doing what can i do for you
sarin did you hear on the news i hear
stalker cases are on the rise
it's scary a woman like me you see i
have to be careful all the guys are
always staring at me so
you be careful too
well you don't have to worry as much as
i do
being as ugly as you are but you should
watch out either way thank you my
self-confidence is through the roof
dark mocha chip
chill pacino please dark mocha chip
chill
dark
dark mocha chip chili dark dark mocha
chip
dark mocha chip
chocolate chip chili pacino okay blended
ice coffee milk
chocolate sauce cocoa butter got it
take this
uh
uh no take this take this take
this take this take this
take this take this take this
take this take this take this take this
take this take this this this this
take
this take this take this
take
this
take this
take this take
this
[Music]
take that take
this take this
take this take this take this take that
take this
chocolate sauce coffee blended iced
chocolate stuff cocoa powder milk
isn't that what it was
yeah
take this take this no take that take
this take this take this take that take
this
there you go
have a lovely day you be careful out
there i don't
you didn't go anywhere
all right you know ugly people like me
don't have to be too concerned about the
um
trappings of the modern world and the
problems thereof
hi
okay
dance troupe hi
a match cake please
stop pushing me
assaulted caramel mocha
then i'll have a matcha chili pacino you
always can't finish your drink so let's
share man sure let's do that
one pumpkin cake
i think i'll have something to eat too
you can order first
i'll have a hot cocoa
hot cocoa are you serious i don't have
any money right now
you should have said that first come on
i'll buy you one what do you want to
drink
[Music]
god to say these guys
no it's not like that but really
anything is fine
really i want a white mocha
don't get any food no uh just a drink
oh come on let's order some food
but okay american waffles
waffles
okay where are you looking at
did you hear that noise what noise
noise one noise
i didn't hear it either
it's probably nothing yeah probably
must be your imagination that happens
from time to time
this i made up my mind an apple pie
would that be all yes that's all
okay
so we have
okay we have a matcha pacilla pacino a
salted caramel mocha one white mocha one
matcha cake pumpkin cake american waffle
and apple pie
wow
can't believe you remembered all that
it's almost as this was written in front
of me on a list we'll be waiting i'm
sure you will
holy crap
okay let's do the pastries first okay um
good god okay good god okay uh
matcha chiffon cake
wham
pastry bag
wham uh that's the match cake
okay we've got i believe there was a
pumpkin cake needed
why the music stop
uh
oh okay
okay
um
we had american waffle and an american
apple pie
not those
american waffle
american scone nope
that's not it american apple pie and
then we also had an american waffle
american waffle when
let's see this is the
oh my god what did i i got the waffle
second okay
waffle
let's see
nope
american apple pie
wham okay and now drinks okay salted
caramel mocha
who
saw the caramel mocha uh coffee steamed
milk caramel syrup oh
god okay not you oh my god coffee
steamed milk
uh
that's soy milk no no i'm just flooding
my inventory
i didn't think that this was going to be
part of it caramel chocolate hazelnut
okay let's see let's put this here
chocolate sauce
wait chocolate sauce caramel syrup very
different
caramel syrup
and then
uh
hazelnut syrup okay got it hazelnut
syrup the milk is in there
okay
oh my god
what is this steam milk chocolate okay
and that's all right i do believe
yes
pop a lid on this
grab that put that there
it's all caramel mocha
wham there's one
holy crap uh matcha chili pacino didn't
i do that already
isn't that oh my god white mocha okay
white mocha white mocha steamed milk
white chocolate sauce got it that's easy
put that there put that there put that
there there i have milk in my venturi
wham
that there
white chocolate sauce
chocolate sauce put that there put that
there put that there
slam that there there there there
there there
white mocha bam
what else i got matcha chiller pacino
okay matcha chili pacino okay blended
iced coffee milk uh
much powder whipped cream okay
there's no coffee in that
there's no coffee blended ice milk got
it
okay
what was that
okay
ice
matcha powder
milk
whipped cream
where's the whipped cream where would
whipped cream be where would whipped
cream be
ah
hey
i am a barista
okay bye everybody you guys file out i
can't wait to see you on broadway
it's gonna be really exciting once you
actually get your dances in order
see you later tips are appreciated okay
thank you
i'll just be here being ugly
wow
must have been some pretty high
strong coffee
hello
weren't you in here earlier hi
here's my order
what
what what is what
latte
that's steamed milk i do believe
there you go thanks so much for your
patron whoa
[Music]
i'm a private investigator
that's great you spot anything
suspicious around the area
there have been numerous reports of
people getting harassed
i was wondering if you'd seen anything
in the store
call me if something ever happens
try closing the store early if you don't
want to get in trouble
okay i don't know how to do that that
wasn't in an instructional type sir sir
sir what do you mean by
harassed am i in danger or am i just
going to be annoyed
what
what sweet sweet
[Music]
okay
um
sweep
swippity sweep swap swap bitty swoop
[Music]
okay
sweeping in the darkness
sweet pretty
sweet sweepity swoop
sleepity swoop sweeping
oh my god
okay
this is fine
i remember seeing a power thing over
here
okay
nothing better be over there i have a
broom
i have a broom
i have a broom
have
spilled milk
i ain't gonna cry about it
this build spill spilled milk
[Applause]
what is that about what what what's the
deal with that
why can't i trash this is there any more
spilled milk i'm supposed to find
hello
spells belmont
why is there so much spell milk
who's spilling milk
huh
who's spilling all this milk
huh can't seem to trash oh because i
still have the broom
maybe okay
what what is that
what what what what huh what is why
huh
what what what
look i don't wanna
i'm looking closely
oh it's a haunted mill can i go home now
i guess i got free milk so maybe i
shouldn't be so uh concerned maybe i put
it away
put back milk ah
i don't know if that milk would be
terribly good
okay i'm just the sound of steam and
milk
nothing to be too terribly concerned
about
what am i looking at
why am i looking at it
what is it
ah okay hi ho hi ho after work i go
i guess is that what i'm doing is is
that the pad
um
okay
[Music]
maybe someone lost their phone again
[Music]
hello guess i'll just go to work i'm
sure that there was probably something
that i needed to see over there but i
can't be bothered to actually take a
look at it
[Music]
hey boss
is me
senpai
it's me
[Music]
senpai
senpai
hey seriously you're late again did you
oversleep i'm so sorry
no not i'm so sorry i want you to not be
late this is the second time
i'm sorry a little more enthusiasm would
help don't you think
why don't you ask your mama to wake you
up
okay
dick when you ask her
let me ask your mama to
raise you better maybe
i'm not gonna try to talk hey wow you
have the widest face i've ever seen and
that's a compliment
oh
god oh my god oh my god okay
you want a caramel coffee apple pie
waffle waffle fries apple pies american
stone caramel
coffee
matcha cake
pumpkin cake green bean casserole and
strawberry sweet cream roll
bread beans butter beans red bread and
butter bread
okay american scone carob on top you got
it one of those
[Music]
oh
oh god damn it
uh
waffle okay
waffle
all right food items we got
oh my god what do we got apple pie
caramel coffee american waffle
and then you got yourselves just a
coffee that's a lot of sugar but i am
not judging
one coffee coming right up
there you go good sir you have a good
day now you have a good day and
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait a minute
ah
hey girl
thank you very much
you look impressed no need to
that me i've been living here for more
than 15 years hey girl something's not
right about this place i didn't think
that because i'm not around town
something about the store
what about that person that i saw on the
left over there maybe because of that
guy over there
uh
huh
i guess it was just my imagination are
you haunted by any chance well maybe i
am who's talking
either way i'm running late so i'm going
to have to go
so long
bye
what
the hell who was over there
[Music]
i needed
who was there
who is there hi hi hi hello hi how are
you you coming in the store you want to
fight me you don't know what you're
getting into you don't know who you're
tussling with you know how much muscle
you're about oh you're coming in the
store oh you're approaching me
oh you're actually approaching me
[Music]
hi
[Music]
not uh
much for words huh
vanilla chili pacino milk milk you
you
you just want milk is that what i'm
getting right
you
you literally just want milk
do you want a cup of milk you want you
want a cup of milk
is it is this what i'm understanding is
that what i'm getting
all right okay milk milk um i gotta look
up a vanilla chili pacino you please be
there when i come back blended ice milk
vanilla syrup vanilla powder got it
extra milk huh
this is one of those uh
big milker days you know what i mean
so this is
what is it coffee it's coffee vanilla
milk
it's nothing there's no coffee in this
whatever you say pal whatever you say um
vanilla syrup
and vanilla powder
okay um have a good day
you take care now you here you enjoy
your milk you're staying oh god you're
staying oh god you're staying
oh oh god you're saying
[Music]
okay hi
hello
you're cute can i have your number
uh
[Music]
would you like to order anything hmm
your heart
i think it'll go with your
recommendation what's your name tell me
your name i
love the time only double chocolate
chili pacino i see what's your phone
number
i'm that good looking aren't i i lose
words myself i'm quite popular around
here
now it's your chance
i don't know how you pronounce that word
i'm going to give you a double chocolate
chill of pacino
what's with the attitude
i'm just your friendly neighborhood
barista you'll regret this i'm going
home
is
where where's your home
you
you going home or what you said you were
gonna go home so i'm really eagerly
awaiting there you go you found your way
good job there oh very well done
oh wow look at you you can coordinate a
car
all right
let me just
close that
and bust ye old tables
do i bust the tables how do i do that i
didn't get an instructional video on how
to bust the
oh
okay
any this door's open that's fine
okay
[Music]
okay
cleaning rag here we go this is probably
what it's all about
case busting
boss embossing
juice boxing
busties tables
busting
i don't think there's a way out there
city bus
what is that
oh good oh
good
why
[Music]
okay
okay all right
okay
i'm fine with this
i'm fine with this
this is all good
[Music]
oh my god we'll punch you
watch where you watch where you're going
who is this young one these days i know
babies right
ah damn oh wow you know i feel like it's
kind of cold out for your baby to be so
under clothed all right okay all right
you have a good day now you have a good
day you have real good day
you have a good day now
you hear you have a real good day
this is my car
[Music]
yep
it sure is
[Music]
oh
ah
oh boy
uh-huh
great
good
great
hey boss i'm probably late again
what are you gonna do fire me
senpai
oh hello
what
yeah i was gonna but we're
oh
hi
today is your first closing shift it
wasn't before what do you mean i have a
question do you get strange customers
around at night
well sometimes we do but focus on the
work they're planning to do actually i'm
afraid i might be being stalked
you want to believe someone is
interested in the likes of you
how did you survive childhood how did
you make it this far in life without
someone caving in your skull i guess
i'll come flying to help you if anything
ever happens
i won't if anything happens to you which
i suspect that something might very soon
okay okay
did i hear
hi
oh my god
hello
sorry i'm going to the bathroom can you
order a macchiato for me okay
i'll have a cinnamon roll churros and a
cup of coffee please and add whipped
cream to it
you're gonna eat that much
no wonder you got so fat
huh
hang separately together is fine and
i'll have a matcha chili pacino
what a chiller pacino you can't be
serious do you know how cold it is right
now i'll be fine oh and what did mary
want again
didn't she say she wanted a macchiato
you mean chill pacino she's gonna catch
gold
no she won't
you know i would be fine but mary won't
be
you didn't hear what i said earlier
right
hear what
a caramel macchiato hot please
a hot caramel macchiato got it what
i don't remember any of this
photo god it's still here matcha chilled
pacino strawberry cream roll strawberry
churro strumming cream roll
[Music]
okay
strawberry churro do i have those
strawberry churro i do apparently
okay we got ourselves a strawberry and
cream rule
wham
we got ourselves a strawberry churro
here there you go thank you very much
all right getting started on this coffee
and whipped cream let's get a coffee
going
get some whipped cream on there bad boy
sublam wham blam boom
[Music]
coffee whipped cream there you go thank
you very much matcha chili pacino i
think i remember what that is but uh
matcha powder whipped cream got it wham
wham splam bam bam put that there get
the cold cup put the matcha powder in
there blend it i slam it in there it's
got milk it's got whipped cream it's got
all the goodies that everybody could
possibly want on a
lovely cold evening there you go matcha
chilled pacino
we got ourselves a caramel macchiato we
got some why do these keep slamming we
got some with good taste here steamed
milk caramel syrup caramel sauce
you got it
easy peasy put that there get the
milk steaming
slam that there put that there we go
caramel sauce and caramel syrup blam
blam put the steamed milk right in that
bad boy slam a lid on there bam boom wow
swam you're welcome
you have a lovely day now don't forget
your friend oh you're here you're
staying here all right cool
thanks i'll pay you back i'm sure you
won't oh to be beautiful if only hey
what are you doing
you looking at coffee beans are you
trying to steal something
oh god oh my god oh oh my god we got
twitchies
and twitters
hi nice jacket
[Music]
200 yens for 270 yen can't afford it i
could hear him breathing
what are you what are you talking about
i'll pay the rest
[Music]
but
be good samaritan that's what my father
always told me
it's cold today so during something warm
yeah
for someone like me for someone like me
what if he abducts me scared what are
they talking about over there
seeing any ghosts lately what
what what happened i can't pay attention
to all this
help
should we tell the police or something
what do you mean
what
huh
what was that about
i don't know must be the stress of
poverty
poor guy
get it uh i'm sorry
i'll have a vanilla latte oh
okay
latte i believe that's steamed milk
[Music]
whoa
right bye
steamed milk blam oh ammo
one latte right there we're getting a
vanilla latte which i'm imagining is
pretty similar to a regular old latte
except it has vanilla in it
let me actually see what it has in it
before i do that
vanilla latte
yep just vanilla syrup vanilla syrup you
got it glamour ammo
splamb
there you go thank you very much
don't pay attention to any ghosts
hope nothing haunts you i'm sure
nothing's going to hunt me while i'm
here alone
what just happened what's
it's snowing oh that's lovely all right
just gonna
bust some
bussin
[Music]
boss in the table
buzzin
the tables
just buzzing tables
just
busting
tables
oh hi
hello
hello
uh
hello
hello
oh
oh creepy taste oh the day we first met
yes at chillis she smiled at me like a
flower just thinking about it makes my
heart pound i have never felt this way
before i wonder if she is putting a
smile on everyone's face like she does
mine
[Music]
does this look like a smile on my face
okay what am i looking at
i have so many questions about what's
going right in front of me
okay all right
what
was that
what was it
what was that
what huh
i know her best maybe after your mother
and father i'll really be number one in
time
she picked up my phone and went out of
her way to give it to me
i knew she felt the same way i did we
are in love
today is our anniversary
oh
great
i don't know if i want to
good
[Music]
okay we're fine
oh well that ends well
[Music]
okay
hope no random moms jump out at me
[Music]
okay
good
anybody in my backseat
anybody creeping around the corner
anybody in this van
i wouldn't be able to see you because it
was dark last time so
going to work
huh
car won't start i have to take the bus
do i
do i
do
oh boy
oh boy
bus bus bus bus
bus
[Music]
bus
ah good great good ah
wait for bus
in the cold
all alone
oh
okay
this is fine
what the hell just happened now did you
stop so suddenly
oh my god
no there is no need
hi
there's no need there's no need
okay
[Music]
oh oh oh oh why why the ringing why the
ringing
why why the ringing
wide off the ringing
why wide off the ringing
hey bosh uh might be late again but hey
at least you're still an [ __ ]
senpai senpai
you uh
you're in the toilet
senpai
no my god
that's what you get [ __ ] you scared the
[ __ ] out of me what's awfully convenient
you're in a bath
what the hell
leave me alone i'm in the restroom god
damn it
get to work okay goodbye
uh
oh my god
oh my god okay
good god all right hello
all right i'll get this
two cam
hi two caramel
coffee
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god two caramel macchiatos you got
it
god that makes me so incredibly
uncomfortable
i'm getting surprisingly good at this by
the way i'm i'm actually kind of
impressed with myself all right you have
a good day now hi
hey
how are you doing
good to see you
phone guy right you're that phone guy
can i help you
[Music]
hey hey hey hey nice bernous
how are you doing how you doing how are
you doing what can i do for you what can
i do for you i'd like
i'd like a green tea latte and one of
those waffles too hungry tea laffer and
a waffle yeah the green tea latte and
the waffle here are delicious i always
goes for those two glad you like them
i'll thank you for serving them my son
likes him too
are you alone i'll give you this if you
like this rosary bracelet is said to
ward off evil you should keep it i
bought it from an infomercial on tv they
said some amazing things about it can
you believe it for only
900 yen
oh it's fine i own a lot of them anyways
in this day and age it's so convenient
to buy things through the cell phone
they are only a few presses of buttons
away
okay thank you
green tea latte and american waffle
you got it ma'am
there you go ma'am have a good oops well
i'll just hold on to this
rosary bracelet
oh god i thought i saw
god damn you gotta be cold
you okay
you uh you all right
you okay
sister aren't you a cute one are you by
any chance a model or something no
nothing in particular
but i am incredibly handsome and or
beautiful what a waste i'm sorry but you
should definitely make use of the style
you got i mean do you want me to
introduce you to my office give me your
number sorry i'm not sure about that
kind of thing i see i don't care if you
regret it
i'll have a salted caramel mocha please
okay
you got it
salted caramel mocha coffee female
caramel hazelnut chocolate sauce okay
chocolate sauce caramel syrup
steamed milk and hazelnut something
hazelnut syrup got it
[Music]
hazelnut syrup
blam blam blam and uh thank you ma'am
you have a good day now
you have uh have fun out there
[Music]
you take care stay warm now
[Music]
did you just sashay
as you turned i like that are you not
cold or are you not cold oh you are
sashaying
my god you are
[Music]
it's so hot today of a caramel chili
pacino
excuse me sir could could you please put
some clothes on and not make a scene ah
come on i won't be here long
no it would not so legally that's out of
the question
wait what
girl you know a lot about laws itself
but i'm a guy right so if it's just the
top shouldn't be fine
penal code article 174
a person who commits an indecent act in
public shall be punished by imprisonment
with work for not more than six months
or a fine of not more than three hundred
thousand yen or by detention or a fine
in this case even if it does not
constitute public indecency it is an
extremely insane act that is out of the
ordinary to be naked at such time a year
isn't it in that case drug use is also
suspected right
i'm going home as you should goodbye
also uh one of the latest stages of
hypothermia is feeling extremely warm
it's very counterintuitive process you
might want to go to a doctor
i guess i gotta clean the toilet
senpai's lovely residue i'll call it
okay
clean out the trash huh i only got three
bags but there's four more objectives i
don't like that
i don't like that
[Music]
where's the last crash
ah
i see
[Music]
am i done
oh
that's new
oh rosemary rosary i don't have a rosary
what is that supposed to be
what is that supposed to be hey oh hi
what would you like what can i get for
you how would you how what is latte you
love hey would you like a latte hockey
shoe
yes when a demon walks into your
cafeteria
and orders the latte you get the demon
the goddamn latte okay all right good
great latte coming up latte you want a
latte you get a latte
all the latte you could want hello who
are you did you get a latte i'll take a
latte we love latte
good thing i'm uh real good at making
lattes
probably the best i might say
sure wish i kept that rosary wherever
the hell that went oh well latte coming
up enjoy your latte
anybody want a lot latte latte another
latte uh coming up
a lot of lattes
latte someone even there i can't even
tell who are you i don't care
have a good day oh hey would you like a
latte
i'm assuming that a lot more people
would like lattes
latte coming up latte i'm i'm latteing
as fast as i can okay
i'm just gonna preemptively get a new
latte going
[Music]
latte
latte
latte there you go hey
all right okay the latte rush has ended
oh no it hasn't
what is this latte
[Music]
i'm going to make a latte
oh god
i it's too latte
one latte for me to go
hmm
oh i'm stuck oh i'm stuck i'm stuck
i'm doomed
i'm sorry
would you like a latte
back to work i go
can't wait to have another fun day at my
great job
oh
okay
oh
okay off to work i go then
i'm not really going to question
anything that was going on in my fever
dream is because clearly those were just
a dream and not a
just
come at me
i will kill you i'll kill you i'll kill
you
i'll kill you i'll rip your dick off
i'll rip your balls out
i'll eat your spleen
[Music]
probably fine
probably nothing my imagination
hey boss uh
i see
wait
why
why
why
my phone's already here wait why why
wait where
[Music]
hi
oh it's you
so my suspicions were true i'm glad you
contacted me
calling the police won't help
all they'll do is brush things off to
lessen their workload which is why you
have people like me i'll take a look
around and see if i can find anything
thank you
when did i call the door okay
no closed doors gonna stop you
hello
hi
how are you
welcome
salted caramel mocha here is so
delicious i think you'll love it senpai
okay i guess i'll try that then one
salted caramel mocha i'll have a dark
mocha chip chill pacino
assuming you're not getting salted
caramel mocha
yeah i want to try something different
today i already had one today
i see but a chili pacino on a date like
this you are so young
because it's delicious how would you
like to pay your bill oh is today the
day of the photo shoot or something is
the store going to be featured in a
newspaper uh no i don't think so why
what but i saw someone outside taking
pictures huh was he taking pictures of
this store
yeah the store and you most likely
damn it should have done my makeup
what are you talking about i'm sorry
we'll pay together the drinks are on me
what are you sure thank you so much
i'm in a good mood lately my son used to
be a shut-in and is in a better mood now
that he's going to school your son's in
middle school right
yeah i just hope he wasn't bullied at
school
i didn't have any good memory when i was
in it yes all right cool
great
what i have i still have a latte here
okay salted caramel mocha you got it
i believe that's steamed milk
uh let me just double check i don't want
to be wrong salted caramel mocha yeah
that's the caramel syrup hazelnut syrup
and chocolate sauce chocolate sauce
caramel syrup hazelnut syrup
steamed milk
plopper on there bam boom bam that's the
salted caramel mocha
choc chocolate chip chili pacino
uh blended iced coffee milk chocolate
sauce cocoa powder got it bam bam bam
bam bam bam bam bam
cold cup coffee blam blam blended ice uh
let me double check that let's see milk
chocolate sauce cocoa powder got it
chocolate sauce
cocoa powder never had to do any of
those top ones i guess they don't exist
anyway
all right wham bam bam blam blam and
that's chocolate chip chill pacino all
right you two have a good day now
good luck with your modeling career
who's taking a picture
feel like i should be concerned about
that
i feel like i should be very concerned
about that
oh you
hey you with the ugly baby and you with
the ugly
hey how you doing
how you doing no baby today okay that's
interesting
[Music]
what
what
salted caramel what
what
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry
you okay
okay bye
i don't want to say i told you so but
you were pushing your baby around in the
winter
no clothes oh god
maybe just you just had a cold
[Music]
what is that sound what am i hearing
what am i
hearing what am i hearing
something scratchy what is happening
[Music]
what am i here
what am i here
[Music]
what is that what am i hearing
hello
hmm
that's strange
ma'am oh
i'm sorry
give me the usual
i don't know what the usual is
sweet beans butter beans okay salted
caramel mocha i just did one of those i
should be able to remember
steamed milk
chocolate sauce caramel syrup hazel
syrup put in the milk bam
that's the salted caramel mocha and then
we've got a caramel macchiato
caramel syrup caramel sauce steamed milk
okay pretty much the same except without
the chocolate
no one ever gets soy milk i've never
seen that yet
there you go
hey
are you repairing the store's antenna at
this hour antenna
no ma'am
why
i saw someone on the roof
what
there shouldn't be anybody on the roof
could be the investigator maybe i should
check it out
it could have been my imagination
anyway the drink please i gave that you
have it's in your hand
okay well i'll go check out whatever
that is
i'm guessing i need the ladder no
oh
okay
i was right
hello
oh
that's interesting
climb
this is interesting
hello oh god
no what is that
what
what what is that
where where where would where would this
go
oh
oh oh
i have to close i have to go do i
fast why what do you mean
what do you mean close the door
unlock the door what do you made
close this door what do you mean close
this door how do i close the star
oh my god what does this even mean what
is
what do i what do i do what am i doing
what am i closing how do i close oh god
what do i do close i'm closing the store
count counting
this is horrible
there's been someone living here
somebody's been living here
oh god what what am i doing
what am i doing take out pastry why am i
doing it
wait a minute get the my god the money
why
do i have the money
why do i have the money
money count the money
okay
i don't know the general procedure am i
supposed to old i see
[Music]
okay
flip the clothesline i'm doing it
it's closed
we're
closed
not
available
[Music]
do i
how do i
do i
it's her gun
my god
[Music]
what okay so i need to
close
okay
um
i've got a knife some some got a knife
i've got a knife device
very nice knife
what if i have a knife what
so we have about uh
broom
what about a broom
oh ladder oh interesting um
okay how about i
that's andy i like the sound of this huh
um
ah
yes
yes
of course that's why i needed me to have
the ladder okay i'm up here can i drop a
break
hey where are you at
where are you at
where are you at
i guess i go back down is that what i do
hmm
i could chuck a brick off
somewhere here i gotta get eyes on the
target
[Music]
okay i've got a brick
and i've got
a screwdriver
and if i use these correctly
i will not
die
[Music]
now how
do i do that
where'd you go you're not there anymore
you're not there anymore
hmm
okay so if i have a brick what could i
do with a brick can i set up like a trap
with the brick
cleaning equipment what do i have what
do i have i've got hot coffee i could uh
defend myself with hot coffee
how do i drop things is there is there a
button to drop something
is there a button to
i feel like there's a button to drop oh
oh
interesting
well this is taking a while
is there like a wait up oh my god
oh my god i shouldn't have stopped
i sh i shouldn't have stopped
i probably should have done something
else that brick
[Music]
i feel like there was something else i
was supposed to do
where am i what am i doing
my car keys i didn't have them before
interesting
so i'm outside i have a brick
and a screwdriver
what do i do with these tools there's a
dead body over there so he was inside
that's the investigator okay
interesting
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'm going
oh my god i don't have the right thing
drive i'm driving
why would i wait
[Music]
i didn't check my back seat
huh
okay
oh i didn't check my back seat
ah
god i didn't check my oh okay all right
okay okay okay okay so i'm flipping this
closed all right i got i got i got it i
got it i got it i got it i need this
okay i got i got it
you put this there grab the screwy
driver there go up here and then grab a
brick
okay so now that i have the brick i
don't think i do anything else
do i
i think i just
closed this
use the screwdriver on this
but before
i get in the car i smash the back window
with a brick and i smash him in his nog
okay
car keys
and he's
in my back seat
uh huh
[Music]
uh-huh
no no no no why did i get this brick
then
why did i get the brick
there must have been something else to
do with the brick and it's not driving
off that's gonna be it some kind of a
trap there's a reason to get this brick
there was a reason
it's not just running off either is it
i should take the car
should i
should i really
oh i can get back in
interesting fascinating
what am i missing
clearly i got back in
okay
okay
i don't need another brick
oh
i could have oh i could have clambered
up here
ah i didn't see that okay okay okay i i
didn't see that you could actually run
up that okay that makes a lot more sense
i get why that's there now i should be
able to bash him on the head with this
brick and that would help me escape um
which means i gotta retry but i think
that is the right approach
okay brick climb up i have brick
i see you drop brick
[Music]
oh well bam
that's what you get
[Music]
i killed a man as i picked up the brick
that man looked right at me if i didn't
drop it i thought he would somehow get
inside and kill me that man looked
terrifying i don't even know him
why did he i had no choice i didn't mean
to kill him i was scared i ran to the
police i told the police everything that
happened then the police took me back to
the scene and that man was no longer
there there was no one there
the police took me back home and told me
to leave the rest to us and went back to
investigate the scene
it's all over
i'm tired after all that happened now i
want to rest peacefully
at home
am i watching this tv it doesn't seem to
be like a
show
um
the cable is acting really weird again i
should call the owner
uh
uh oh
where's my phone
uh oh oh no
oh no my tootsies
go outside
that's an outside
why is that an outside i didn't even
know that was an outside what do you
mean that's an outside
oh balcony oh oh right that makes
oh
well that's weird
i'm sure this is totally fine
100
a-okay
i'm gonna go get my phone now
la la la la la
[Music]
this is what someone call not good
some you know not everyone but oh boy
yeah this ain't a trap
[Music]
i still have a screwdriver
i'll screw
you oh boy
well i definitely gave a chance for
someone to get in my apartment
[Music]
great
well i'm dead
problem oh
oh good
great
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh good that's just how it ends great
okay good to know
ah man that's a different kind of horror
because it's just like a very real
horror
it just is and it's oh it's disgusting
and it's terrifying creepy to the bone
i hate it that's a horror experience
yeah
it was just weird across the board just
like with the the whole barista element
was so
realistic honestly it was kind of fun
doing the the making the coffee stuff i
was getting good at it but
just was like i bet if you go through
the footage you would see like all these
other moments that i missed
got the milk
good thing i had a screwdriver so my
canon is i did a swift turn stabbed
right in the eye straight through the
occipital bone and into the brain
killing instantly
wonderful but anyway this was very good
uh there are actually a lot more horror
games from this particular developer i'm
not sure of the quality of all of them
this was very good minus like obviously
the graphics and the modeling and all
that stuff was a little bit janky but
jackie's okay
janky is a-okay
my review
thumbs up thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see more
scary games they are in the description
if you want to check out in space with
markiplier and you haven't done it yet
it's in the description as well as well
as the annotations check it out you
won't regret it thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you